so
dante for you let's go with
he's basically he's basically the
wingman in a sense
throughout season one but during that
process of bringing dash and lily
together what do you think that he
learned about himself that he might take
on to season two
for me i think that he learned
that even though he's a loyal friend he
has a life as well like for him i think
he came
in feeling as if his friendship was like
all that he had but he understood that
he's his own person as well he has his
own friends as well he
cultivates his own relationships but he
can still
be that wingman he can still be that
great friend i think he also learns that
he also
he likes you know he's
he he wants to also find his love so i
think he
he goes into figuring that out as as a
as
anybody would any teenager would you
know troy
how about i guess this is probably one
of my favorite scenes of yours in the
entire
series the moment where he decides to
not give
her the notebook towards the ends
because the camera just sits on you
for a little bit and it lets us see the
wheels in your head turning a little bit
so what specifically is driving
langston's
decision in that moment to not hand over
the notebook yet
i think he's just thinking about the the
the well-being of his baby sister and
realizing that she's dealing with a lot
right now
she's had she's having to move to pretty
much the other side of the world and was
given like less than a week's notice
and you know she just started liking
this guy and that didn't work out so i
think
seeing the notebook of course at first
he's like oh this is your notebook but
very quickly he realizes you know what
she doesn't need this right now
you know it's a little bit too much and
then he snoops
and um realizes oh wait never mind you
should read this
you capture all of that in that one
moment too in that one shot and it's
very
impressive it was definitely right all
right guys i have to let you go but
thank you so much for your time today
and again big congrats on the show it is